determinan si el sistema no tiene
soluciones o tiene una infinidad de
soluciones así que pensemos cómo podemos
resolver esto y para encontrar un punto
lo que hacemos es trabajar con estas
ecuaciones así que vamos a hacer lo
mismo si llegamos a algo que no tiene
sentido entonces significará que no
tenemos una solución o en su dado caso
podemos obtener una solución o una
infinidad de soluciones que es una de
las opciones que tenemos aquí así que
para resolver un sistema de ecuaciones
con 35 órbitas uno de los métodos es ir
eliminando variables una a una
si eliminamos la equis de estas
ecuaciones vamos a obtener un sistema de
dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas la
game y la zeta y así podemos tomar estas
ecuaciones en pares con la idea de
eliminar la variable x podremos por
ejemplo tomar las primeras dos y
eliminar equis y después no se tomar
otro par de ecuaciones tal vez las dos
últimas y de la misma manera eliminar a
la equis y además estas ecuaciones
conservan toda la información de este
sistema con tres ecuaciones y bueno
también cabe decir que podríamos tomar
el par restante pues
además es decir la primera y la tercera
ecuación pero bueno como lo que yo
quiero es eliminar a la equis me voy a
tomar primero estas dos ecuaciones la
primera y la segunda y para eliminar a
la equis date cuenta que tengo que
convertir la primera en que tenga el
principio 1 - 8 x porque si tienen el
principio en menos 8 x menos 8 x más 8 x
se cancelarían y entonces ya solamente
me quedaría todo en términos de ley y de
zeta así que para hacer esto lo más
fácil es multiplicar la primera ecuación
por menos 4 y que me va a quedar me va a
quedar 4 por 2 menos 4 por 2 es menos 8x
que es justo lo que yo quería menos 8x
después me queda menos x menos más 4 x 4
16 16 bien y después menos 4 por zeta me
queda menos 4 z y esto es igual a 3 for
menos 4 lo cual es menos 12 perfecto y
la segunda ecuación la voy a pasar igual
para que se pueda cancelar los términos
que tienen que ver con xy me queda 8 x
menos dos y más 4 z igual a 7 georges y
voy a sumar estas dos ecuaciones a ver
que obtengo del lado izquierdo me queda
menos 8 x
y se cancelan después 16 germain 2 y
esto es lo mismo que 14 y 16 menos 10 14
y muy bien y después tengo menos 474 z
lo cual también se cancelan estos dos se
van esto fue porque multiplicamos por
menos 4 y bueno del lado derecho que me
va a quedar me queda menos 12 más 7
menos 12 + 7 es lo mismo que menos 5 14
y es igual a menos 5 y esto estaría
bastante bien si lo que buscamos fuera
la solución de este sistema lo que
podremos hacer de aquí es despejar al
aire y encontrar el valor explícito de y
aunque aquí no tuviera z
sin embargo voy a dejar este despeje por
ahorita es lo que quiero hacer es
enfocarme en las otras dos ecuaciones 14
y es igual a menos 5 ya me voy a fijar
en las siguientes dos ecuaciones que va
a ser la segunda y la tercera de la
segunda y la tercera de lo que voy a
buscar es también eliminar la equis y
por lo tanto la segunda ecuación la voy
a pasar igual 8 x menos 2 yemas 477
mientras que la tercera ecuación lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar la x menos 2
para qué
pueda cancelar la equis entonces para
ponerlo de aquí acá voy a multiplicar
por menos 2 no espera de hecho voy a
multiplicar por 2 positivo porque si te
das cuenta lo que quiero es que se
cancele la equis y necesito un menos 8 x
y aquí tengo menos 4 x menos 4 por 2 me
da menos 8 x que es justo lo que yo
quiero para que se cancelen entonces
menos 8x después me quedaría 2 por james
lo cual me va a dar más 2 de positivo
después menos 12 está por 2 me quedan
menos 4 z y para finalizar menos 14 por
2 me da menos 28 y entonces voy a
eliminar todo lo que se pueda de estas
dos ecuaciones y de aquí estas dos se
cancelan estas dos se cancelan estas dos
también se cancelan y por lo tanto del
lado izquierdo de la ecuación me queda
nada me queda solamente 0000 es igual a
cero mientras que por otra parte del
lado derecho queda menos 21 y esto es
bastante bizarro no tiene sentido que 0
sea igual a menos 21 sea cual sea la x y
z que te tomes en estas ecuaciones en
ningún momento te va a dar que 0 es
igual a menos 21 y esto es porque estas
dos últimas ecuaciones
vemos aquí si las vemos representadas
con un plano en r3 estas dos de aquí no
se intersectan no se intersectan de
hecho situ las visualizas en tres
dimensiones son planos paralelos y si
entonces estos planos que representan
las ecuaciones en r3 no se intersectan
entonces podemos concluir que no tenemos
soluciones esto sin importar lo que nos
dice el primer plano pues aunque los
interceptaran la intersección nos daría
una infinidad de soluciones pero
fijarnos en el último plano no existe la
terna x 10 eta que cumpla las tres
ecuaciones simultáneamente pues no
existe un solo punto que satisfaga estos
dos planos al mismo tiempo pues son dos
planos paralelos y no se intersectan